[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
59 reason to wag your tail and point
your snout in the air
all right it's q a time it's q a time
here we go
we'll begin with a few questions from
the last time as we do
have you guys rift on jealousy the
emotion through the evolutionary lens if
so i'll look for that
thanks for all you've done in 2020 um
i'm not sure if we have rift on it
specifically
um let's say a little here and we can
come back to it all right
um so first of all jealousy like so many
things is an
adaptation right all negative emotions
would have to be how else would they
have come into existence
now jealousy obviously has implications
you know if we take sexual jealousy for
example
it has a role to play in maintaining a
pair bond
right that is to say um policing
your pair bond such that it does not
come apart on you or
get parasitized or whatever it is um is
obviously
a an important thing to do to the extent
that pair bonds are also
an adaptation hey that's more cats than
usual
um so anyway there's that we might have
an infestation we have
we have something close to an
infestation so the only other thing i
would say is
that it's fascinating and not surprising
that because
male and female are real phenomena
whoa i know real phenomena and because
male
and female not only are they real but
they're different um
that the sexual jealousy
is distinct between males and females in
a predictable way
because that is to say that the things
that threaten a
male and a female are distinct
so we can historically have been
reliably throughout
history and slightly less distinct now
in the modern era but still the patterns
of jealousy across sex hold
right they hold and so they are let's
say generally
um males have a lot to lose
evolutionarily speaking
if they end up investing in offspring
that are not genetically theirs
now it may be that we shouldn't give a
damn about this because who the hell
cares about whether or not your children
have your genetic spellings for their
enzymes or not
but we are wired to care about it
because those of us who were more wired
to care about it out competed those of
us who were less wired to care about it
so
males and by the way this is a feature
that females
carry but do not express that is to say
we all have the human genes with
very few exceptions there are some y
chromosomes
things that women don't have but in
general women have all the same genes
trying to get into the future and so
they express those that
match the um the womanly interaction
with the universe and
they have latent the ones that that uh
match a male pattern
but nonetheless men tend to be very
concerned about sexual infidelity
women have less to lose in sexual
infidelity not zero
sexual influence infidelity can result
in
the loss of a mate to somebody else so
there's reason to be somewhat jealous
over it
it can result in disease or other things
so there are reasons that women should
try to police
the sexual behavior of their mates but
not as strongly as
males what females at least in humans
have to
fear especially is abandonment because
to the extent that raising offspring is
an extremely expensive
behavior signing up with a male to
jointly raise children and then having
him disappear which then
makes that female much less able in
traditional terms
to find a new mate because she's got a
burden that doesn't carry the genes of
whoever the new mate would be
means that uh this is a very serious
matter so in general
men tend to be more uh sexually jealous
and females tend to be more romantically
jealous
and so men tend to be more
concerned about controlling uh physical
infidelity
and women tend to be more concerned
about controlling emotional infidelity
yep
that's that's correct all right so i
think that's a pretty good
that's a good summary primer on uh
sexual jealousy at least and then
there's
time for us to lose all of our
carnivorous oh man
this from last week um are biden's
recent appointments visual or
merit-based curious if evergreen writ
large relates at all
also unity 2020 you were right all along
shocking yeah um yeah you have specific
things to say on uh
no i mean i i like this question enough
that i brought it brought it back up for
this
for this time but um it it feels
it feels like the prediction that we
were making that he would you know he
was going to pander
and um you know it's impossible i mean
this this is the problem
with um with tokenism and
things like affirmative action is that
what if
what if the most qualified person for a
job is in fact a
disabled black woman you hire a disabled
black woman in this environment
and it is going to be nearly impossible
for anyone's first second or even third
interaction with them to assume oh wow
what an awesome person for this job
because of the culture that we're in
it's
it's impossible to know and the person
themself
must recognize that all of their
interactions are tainted with us
yeah uh yeah it's a and you know we
learned this
in the affirmative action era right so
this is a new version of it but you know
we're reinventing the same problem so
yeah i see very little that's hopeful
in biden's appointments i see a lot of
pandering
i see a lot of machine politics
reasserting itself after
uh what may one day be understood as a
refreshing break
in the form of insanity that made no
sense but
it wasn't same all same all yeah it was
a you know
and you know i must say i know i'm just
going to take crap for this because i
always do anytime i
indicate uh any sort of um ambiguity
about which the right side is when
they're both wrong but right
um you know i said when trump was
elected
that at least we were all awake right at
least we were all away we did
and that the thing that i feared um if
clinton had won and
you talked me off the ledge i mean
metaphorically i did and on to a
different ledge but you know it's all
ledges
um but the uh
the fact was there was every danger that
if clinton had won in 2016 that a whole
lot of people were going to feel like
she's not perfect but it's good enough
and um
those of us who regard it as not nearly
good enough and very much a matter of an
intense kind of political corruption
that yes may very frequently be legal
but why would you care about that
right right but the effect of the
corruption is legal is its own problem
it does not make it better yeah right so
uh what we had was a break in the
narrative and the narrative is now
reasserting itself and you can see it
reasserting itself in
biden's appointments and statements and
a lot of people
who saw nothing but the horror of trump
for four years are suddenly gonna feel
like uh
whatever okay it is what it is it is
what it always is and the answer is you
know
that thing that it always is is gonna
get us killed so yeah um
try not relaxing about it you know there
you go
have you read any haruki murakami he is
wonderful and loves to play with our
conceptions of reality worth reading
thank you both and happy holidays
um i have not but i wanted to include
this this question
because um one of our
most amazing students on our last study
abroad trip
was constantly recommending murakami to
me
and i still have not read any of his
work but i have i have
received this recommendation from a
number of sources so
we'll do so and um if anyone has a
particular recommendation for where to
start i would be
interested to hear it cool
how does the rate of mutation affect the
i presume the answer
your answer to that question is no yes i
have not yeah how does the rate of
mutation affect the evolutionary process
can a species of mutation rate be
considered fine-tuned
for the species for optimal evolution
good question
um yeah it has a huge uh implication
and the answer is even better than
you're you're anticipating here
um so there you have rates of evolution
that are highly variable you know
hiv eluded our initial ability to do
anything about it because it was so
rapidly evolving
likewise things like cold and flu are so
rapidly evolving that
you know even if we can make some
inroads against flu for example they're
not durable
so in that case high mutation rate which
has a cost
right a lot of the mutations that occur
in fact the expectation would be the
vast majority of them
make things worse but to the extent that
it discovers some new thing you know you
can afford a lot of dead viruses if you
come up with
some new innovation that um advances the
ball
or evades an extent vaccine for instance
right invades an extent vaccine
or yeah i mean escapes the memory cells
that
yeah yeah either endogenous or exogenous
our
built in our on-board immunity or one
that we've received a shot
right now here's where this gets really
interesting which is
even within a creature the mutation rate
is not one
thing and there is clear evidence that
different
properties are moved around in the
genome and altered with respect to their
rate of mutations you have certain
things like in fact
the adaptive immunity we talked about is
contingent
on a kind of genetic shuffling that
takes place
um so basically there's a random number
generator
phenomenon in the genome
there is also the ability to move things
on chromosomes where they are more and
less prone
to be disrupted and therefore to change
in ways that could be selected so for
example
like more like closer to the chiasma
more and less
susceptible to crossing over right
exactly
uh so i i learned from bill rice who we
mentioned on the program
last time um that the
fastest evolving gene known at the time
and i don't know that it's
changed the creature may have changed
but the um likely the
the process has not the fastest evolving
gene known
was the gene for the acrosomal proteins
in i think it was abalone if i recall
correctly in
the sperm and the idea is that there is
a
the acrosomal proteins are um is that is
it tail proteins or is that like the
coating no it's the protein that enters
the egg
yes that's what i thought there's a kind
of arms race between males
the one that activates the egg first has
an advantage obviously because it shut
down it shuts down the eggs
availability to other sperm so where
there's sperm competition
there's intense selection for a better
formula
and it may be that this is part of an
arms race where there's actually
resistance on the part of the um the
substrate
there's evolutionary resistance on the
part of the egg and so anyway
rapidly evolving proteins in acrosomal
acrosomal proteins in sperm slowest
evolving
genes known are those for histone
proteins
histone proteins being proteins around
which
dna is wrapped partially just to keep it
organized so it isn't a huge tangle that
breaks up and can't function but we have
learned more recently
that the way in which proteins are
wrapped around
i mean the way in which dna is wrapped
around these histone proteins which look
like rods and
balls and they're packed in a very
regular form in fact you can see it in
an electron
micrograph you can see yeah you don't
see
you see these i forget what they're
called nucleosomes
but anyway you see these uh regular
balls that are created by the way that
the dna is wrapped and then there's sort
of a fractal process where it's wrapped
and then it's wrapped at a higher level
and higher level
but anyway the way in which the genes
are wrapped around the histone
proteins dictates whether or not they
are available
for transcription and so
um what this means
is that this is a mechanism for turning
genes on and off so if you think about
the fact that your eye has all the
proteins necessary
to make your liver work but most of
those aren't useful in your eye
so they have to be silent so you can
wrap
genes in such a way that they are
effectively invisible to the cell and
not interfering with anything they're
dormant
so the point is in histone proteins
these are extremely ancient
structures they go back to the beginning
of eukaryotes which you
labeled as how far back your whys 1.2 to
2 billion years 1.2 to 2 billion
years that's a very ancient structure
and the idea is any alteration you would
make to a histone protein
is almost certain to be catastrophic and
not just catastrophic for some process
but catastrophic across the whole genome
because everything is dependent on being
well wrapped and organized so anyway
very slowly evolving
so yeah lowest mutation right there yep
very cool um the next one
we have not yet gotten to these kayaking
and existential threats uh piece i took
a real quick look at it and want to
spend a little more time but we will
come back to it
uh chadwick thank you would you consider
mirroring your content to alternative
platforms such as mines or
rumble uh sure i think
mirroring would be smart in light of the
various hazards that clearly go with
these these big platforms
so yes it would be a good idea okay
question from the discord
uh conversation this week what would be
the evolutionary logic behind
self-imposed celibacy
as seen in clergymen hermits and
philosophers throughout history
gonna have to put this one on pause
except to say
that i thought you're the
the fact is there are lots of ways that
things that cannot reproduce
end up doing the equivalent and so
that's that's that's good yeah it's uh
it's an important
principle so the counter-intuitive thing
is that it's like people
and uh but we will come back to it
uh in proper form with an excellent
long i think satisfying explanation
and uh anyway i'm looking forward to
doing that and if it can't be if it
turns out that this
lockdown stuff is going to go on and on
and on maybe we have to do it some way
other than
renting a hall but it has been my my
hope that we would rent a hall and
yeah have the discussion okay first
question from this last hour
why did you describe the success of the
new alpha fold 2
as scary so this was we had this
conversation a couple weeks ago and i
thought we sort of explored it
in our conversation i find it
more more terrifying than you do and you
um
had a had a more tempered um response
remind me of where we were in that
discussion alph oh so alpha fold two
is the is the google solution the ai
solution to protein folding right and um
i mean this came in this hour
and i felt obliged to read the question
but i'm not sure
i feel like we sort of had the
conversation i don't have anything to
add so i have not been thinking about
this anymore for all right a couple of
weeks so i think i can
i think i can recover it and i would say
the um
my expectation was that there is
actually a
simple logic underlying
um the way proteins fold something that
is
effectively explored closer to what
legos are like
than uh building stuff from the ground
up at a moment
that's right and so my hope i guess
is that what the program did was intuit
something about the heuristics that
go into exploring this space and
therefore
that basically this is hinting at a
discovery we might be about to have but
it does not imply
that the awesome power of artificial
intelligence is right there and we are
standing at the singularity and
etc yeah i guess i mean regardless of
certainly it's less scary the closer to
true that is
the less complex this question actually
was that has just been solved by ai
and is less terrifying but really
whatever
whatever the bounds on that range of
possibilities are
the fact is i don't see any evidence
that anyone thinking in this space with
power to do anything about it is seeing
what they're creating as an evolutionary
process itself
into which checks and balances must be
put as selection would be putting
on organisms such that um
a human being could override a runaway
process that happened
yeah i don't see any evidence that's
happening so that's that's why sort of
any
um ai gains in kind of any space i find
a bit terrifying because i see no
parallel conversation around
what where's where's the kill switch
yeah i don't i
i hope i'm wrong i hope i'm just missing
it i'm not aware of it this is not
a literature conversation i i pay
attention to
but i don't know of it if it's there
well i think there's a lot of thinking
around
runaway ai and what might be done about
it but so far
it's in the context of um
you know libertarian solutions which are
too voluntary to be
workable um so i guess what i would say
is um it is time that we started taking
all of these things like
okay you've got crispr cast nine is this
the end of the world
it's not the end of the world right we
got a typewriter for jeans we don't have
the rosetta stone but the rosetta stone
is coming
it will at that point crisper cast 9
becomes a much more frightening
phenomenon
okay you've got alpha fold too does that
mean that we're about to be able to
design proteins to do whatever we want
and
you know we're going to be molecularly
interfering with the world in a way we
can't
uh undo not yet but it's coming
right so you know likewise gain of
function
mutation research right is
covet 19 the product of such thing uh
could well be
could well be but even if it's not it
could happen so
it's time that we get used to the idea
that our power is now so great
that we're going to be uh you know we're
going to firmly paradox ourselves out of
existence if we don't get
wise really really quickly and so
each one of these things and stop we
need the best brands on
every possible topic so this is not the
moment to be virtue signaling around
immutable characteristics
yeah right we're going backwards um
so yes i think that's the point we got
to stop going backwards it's time to
start going far
forwards at a rate that is conceivably
fast enough
to catch up to the dangers we're
creating and
uh those would have us going backwards
are a threat to the endeavor very
clearly
and many of them aren't contributing
anything good
true i work in tech as an artist this
ideology infects even scholarships
i saw a women in game scholarship evolve
over the years from being for women
to when i don't even know how to
pronounce this
w-o-m-x-n trans and non-binary
i can't help but feel like i'm alone in
my field when i when believing in
meritocracy
yeah so there's no question there but um
i comment and i feel you
it's yes uh yeah
it's uh it's gonna be everything
until we get over the idea that it
should be everywhere that it's
always good to to behave this way yeah
um so this one i kind of remember the
question but i don't remember us
anyway didn't really get an answer to my
question from last time about how people
can stop giving away their power
could you please share your thoughts
also do you have a p.o box for people to
send holiday cards and gifts
so i'm going to look up the po box while
you answer the question
the question is how can you not give up
your power i guess i wish i understood
which version of give up your power yeah
i think we answered some version that
wasn't what this person
uh wanted and we still don't necessarily
know what
right uh is being asked for i mean i
you know i'm going to give you a
placeholder answer since we don't know
exactly what what domain you're talking
about um but
there's something to be said for
advertising for first of all cultivating
your ability to be trustworthy
with power right and
when you demonstrate trustworthiness
with power people are much more likely
not to see
your having power as a problem and to go
about tearing it down
so i would say this is something that
worked very well for us
inside the classroom where we knew our
students and they knew us
which was we demonstrated that we would
do the right thing if we got something
wrong we would come into class and
explain where the error was and upgrade
things and so
as people got the sense that a you did
care about them
b that you were honorable and not lying
to yourself
they were much more relaxed about the
power dynamic whereas
you know otherwise there is an asymmetry
which in the wrong hands
can be abused so i actually i actually
talked about that in my
impact theory conversation with with tom
bilyeu um so that's that's out and i
actually did listen to it which i don't
always listen to these conversations
afterwards but
i recommend it um so there's some stuff
in there about power and
how you can use power effectively um if
if you're interested in pursuing more
impact there impact theory and impact
your podcast is that the name i think so
it's definitely impact theory it's on
all the podcasts and it's also on
youtube
i guess um so we do have po box um
one for um flat stuff and one for
packages po box 1703
lake grove oregon 97035-3401
either of our names on it or for um
things
that are more three-dimensional one five
eight seven five boons ferry road
number 1703 and then same everything
else lake grove
oregon 97035-3401
all right have you read oh i forgot to
get it
have you read matthew walker's book why
we sleep it offers some alarming and
compelling evidence for the way as
modernity has devastated our sleep and
by extension our health
yes it's terrific in our forthcoming
book which
is still months from publication but
will be published
in 2021 we have a list of we have
recommended further readings for each of
our chapters
uh and for our chapter on sleep it is
exactly walker's book
that we recommend as further reading and
of course there's lots of other places
you could go but it really is terrific
so um yeah anyone who's interested
in a savvy careful
nuanced uh understanding of sleep i
recommend at matthew walker's why we
sleep
i lived in la for three years so i must
ask how did two people who grew up in
los angeles end up normal and reasonable
adults
oh well we fled um that's what we did
um yeah yeah
i don't know i i have um i i have a
greater fondness for la than i once did
i had so much
patience for it uh growing up were
you know in the decades after leaving
but
you know i now i i now understand
the value of a
weather pattern that allows you to spend
a lot of time outside even in the winter
i mean i remember as a kid i remember at
one point my parents were very concerned
and they confronted me and asked me to
tell them what order the seasons came in
and you couldn't do it i struggled with
it because you know
wasn't that obvious meanwhile one of the
struggles in my house is that my mom
who grew up in the midwest uh in the
south uh
always wanted me to be wearing socks and
i hated socks i really preferred to be
barefoot and my sense was
it's la why do i need socks yeah i mean
i wonder about these people who think
you should always wear socks
like they don't shower i mean
you're going to hear about that from my
mother who watches these you probably
will hear about that from your mother
but let's jesse if you're watching don't
wear the socks in the shower
just it doesn't end well i think she
knows this
probably yeah she's a very sensible
woman undoubtedly she yeah she does
um yeah no i feel i feel the same way um
i had very little patience i mean i
actually did enjoy um part of la growing
up and then
as i sort of as i came of age as i
as i became a woman it struck me as a
ridiculous place to live especially for
a young woman
and i was so ear not to be there and
couldn't imagine
um ever wanting to go back but um
but it was actually it was one of the
places that we considered moving uh
when we knew we were moving from olympia
right like we actually really did think
about it
that isn't saying very much because we
considered moving just about everywhere
um yeah i don't think that's true but i
mean uh but
la like most places was just um frankly
too expensive not affordable
yeah um but
but yeah there there's a particular kind
of
of crazy um that is in the mindset of a
lot of especially people on the west
side
uh in la and i grew up on the west side
you did not but um
i don't think i think where you group is
considered the west side i don't know
uh i don't i don't know either
uh near the tar pits yeah um not in the
tarpon
no and we called it the pits um no you
didn't no no one ever called it what i'm
thinking
your neighborhood
while the sound check may no longer be
necessary i always enjoyed the ritual
and humor that came with it
i miss it now that it's gone bring it
back as a short lighthearted bit before
the heavier subjects of the show
all right but we need a new reason for
its existence as the tech has become
reliable um so i don't know we'll find
something
okay tj uh said
okay this is gonna be thomas jefferson
said constitution should be rewritten
every 19 years
jordan hall has discussed a jubilee
system wherein reboots occur every 50
years to prevent capturing collapse
do you have thoughts on systematized
civilizational reboots or formalizing
the cycles
we were just working on this final
chapter of our book
um yeah we we definitely do have similar
ideas some of them are not completely
independent um
but yes there is something about the
fact of a
static target being gamed and there is
something to the
idea of a self-refreshing process
the devil however is in the details
because for one thing
if you decide fresh sheet of paper then
you're going to make new mistakes that
you would have gotten over if you had
continued some things so there has to be
some mechanism for sort of
intentionally carrying things over there
has to be some rubric for dealing with
the chesterton's fence
problem there has to be something
precautionary and yes i know every time
you say precautionary principle there's
a whole
group of people who starts clutching
their pearls and looking for their
fainting couch
and um asking for the smelling salts
asking for the smelling salts
um and the fact is precautionary
principle is
difficult to implement but it is vitally
important that we figure out how to take
the spirit of the precautionary
principle
and install it into the system but yeah
and you know what we're smart species we
should be able to figure this out
as species go we're smart ish
that's all you're going to give me
that's all i'm going to give you okay um
here's the thing we have the potential
being so software based
to become very smart and i'm looking
forward to us deciding to do that
brett would you be able to share the how
to for the bike you made
other than the bike and driving to the
amazon
are there other things you did from
first principles that were majorly
rewarding
okay before you talk about bikes you
can't drive to the end you can't drive
to the amazon there's the
whole issue of the darien gap in panama
um through which the pan american
highway does not go
right so for political rather than
geological reasons
you stepped on my joke
you could still say it i don't know what
i'm gonna say no i take it back there
was no joke
okay um yeah you can't drive to the
amazon but um
you could have your car put on a ship
and you could go around the darian gap
but we have never driven to the amazon
we did drive to
uh we got as far as guatemala
once uh from los angeles yes we are
actually
technically probably fugitives in
guatemala i doubt i have a new passport
at this point i
i can now go back to oh i have no doubt
that we could get away with going to
guatemala
at this point speaking i believe that
you at least are a fugitive from justice
in guatemala for having sold a car
without authorization
to a lawyer who gave us paperwork and
then said actually we didn't need it at
all so it was all in the up and up until
we got to the border
it's a long story but yes fugitive from
justice
briefly until i because it had expired
was going to expire
got my new passport at which point i now
feel free to go back to guatemala all
right well yes
we should do that so yeah the secret so
i'm going to tell you the embarrassing
secret it's not so embarrassing but
um you want to build your own bike and
you should it's great
um and in fact it's economically if you
were thinking of
[Music]
buying a custom bike for yourself the
expense of making your own bike
is actually quite reasonable if you have
the couple weeks to do it
but it is the uh
united bicycle institute in ashland
oregon a lovely little town where
there's
very nice biking and nice walking around
in the evening and nice swimming in the
reservoir and all kinds of stuff
and there's not coved uh one of the best
shakespeare festivals in the world
fabulous live theater not just
shakespeare super yup so the united
bicycle institute has
a building there where they have a
school they can teach you
basic mechanics advanced mechanics if
you want to work in a bike shop and
never make any money at all
you could get a advanced certificate for
bike mechanics stuff or you can take
their frame building course
and you can it does the whole thing
probably my guess
my feeling having done it is you should
be technically inclined they say on
their site you don't need to be but i
think you wouldn't
do very well if you didn't have basic
you know skills
you've got to have good hands and a
sense for how that kind of thing works
but you probably wouldn't do it if you
didn't so if you're inclined
you go there you live there for two
weeks you
design your bike based on your
particular measurements and what you
want your bike to do
you draft it and then you
build it you get the parts and you
braise them together
uh or if you're doing a lug frame you
solder them together
and uh it's really spectacular and i
will tell you that riding a bike that
you've built
is is like nothing else it's it's a
great feeling especially if you've
done anything unusual where your bike is
not just like any other bike but
it has special characteristics it's uh
it's a pretty cool thing
and your experience there was also my
40th birthday present to you yes i was
going to say that
it occurred to me that i didn't say it
um this was uh i think probably the
greatest president i
present i ever got i mean it's not
something you were unaware of you you
were you
you had your eye on it yeah you also had
your eye on flight lessons which is part
of why i decided
you never know where it would be if i'd
gotten flight left i don't
probably somewhere else true um
but yeah you can't you can't go as far
on a bike
you can it just takes longer and well i
guess if there's water
yeah you can't cross there and gather
places you can't
you can't bite the amazon yeah well
right okay um
regarding meritocracy most get spit out
the bottom
limited job opportunities for scientists
artists etc means there's no equality of
outcome or
opportunity even with equal ambition and
ability
will ai make equality redundant
try that again regarding meritocracy
most get spit out the bottom there are
limited job opportunities for scientists
and artists etc
which means there's no equality of
outcome or opportunity even for people
with equal ability or ambition etc
will ai make equality redundant
well so i'm struggling over what that
last thing means i think it does mean
we have to engineer a system that isn't
based on the same things because the
idea that
merit is the same thing as productivity
is
wrong right it at one time may have been
some kind of
proxy but we're living in a very
different world and so the real question
is
what would we like people to be doing
what kind of goodness would we like them
to be bringing to the world
and how can we make that remunerative
right and so as we've said here before
it is essential
that we not reach a quality of outcome
that's not a desirable state what you
want
is a state in which people who have
brought the most value to the world
things that are truly valuable rather
than just things that sell
right you want those people rewarded at
the highest rate so that we all
attempt to produce uh things that make
humanity
stronger better happier more fulfilled
freer those kinds of things right now
the question is is there any way to do
that other than architecting
in other words you know the place where
a
traditional libertarian and we would
depart from each other
would be over whether or not there's
something to be done by intentionally
trying to structure the system rather
than
their correct recognition that
intentionally trying to structure
a system carries all kinds of hazards
and that you're actually
pretty likely to screw it up if you
don't have a good mode for figuring out
what actually works and what the
unintended consequences
might be and what you might do to
mitigate them
yes
i don't know how to pronounce this word
i've seen it a lot ivermectin
ivermectin it's an anti-parasitic drug
in use for decades
there is strong evidence for its
efficacy as treatment for covid
but it's being ignored by the mainstream
media and then he has parentheses disc
which is your brother's acronym which
stands for the distributed
idea suppression complex does
this does the presence of ivermectin and
the fact that um
there is a lot of evidence for its
efficacy as a treatment for covid
not significantly alter the vaccine
situation
i don't know nearly as much about
ivermectin as i might
i think it it does it should be being
talked about
i think the one one important way though
that effective treatment is different
from vaccine
is that um there is real concern
from a a number of different across a
number of different
like anatomical physiological domains um
simply having had kovid
may produce itself long-term effects so
even if you treat it such the symptoms
don't go so bad that you end up dying
from it
um with which ivermectin seems i believe
what little i know to be
um effective against um
there is i don't i've never i i at least
have not seen any evidence suggesting
that ivermectin also has the capacity
to um shut down all the any of the
long-term effects how could we know at
this point because right the thing's
only been around the whole
virus has only been known maybe a year
yeah um yes i would say
uh i am beginning to see some very high
quality conversation
about um the foolishness
of a single silver bullet
theory of how we're going to address
this and at some level
it is certainly true that we should have
been way better at generating high
quality testing so that we could in fact
say
who does have it who doesn't have it
with
instead of relying on pcr testing right
all of the testing is bad and it's
creating
a lot of problems including it is
fueling
um conspiracy beliefs
that are not well-founded because it is
very hard to establish that they are
false
and so right um in any case
the we should have had an intense
lockdown
followed by very high quality testing
and
control of the disease where where there
was an outbreak
[Music]
longer term measures should be much more
surgical
a vaccine is great if it works but
running a
huge dangerous experiment by trying to
get everybody vaccinated and certainly
assuming that that
is what uh is the thing that gets us out
of covet is a crazy gamble
i read today something that surprised me
which is i hope this is
correct i don't have it on the ready but
thailand
um had a total thailand which i believe
has
a population of 70 million
has 60 coved deaths total
um so and thailand is not one of these
authoritarian
countries that did all right because
they were able to order people around so
anyway wow and it's got a climate more
like guayaquil and manaus
who which have had uh appalling
appalling death rates right yeah so
anyway we call it
ecuador which we talked about a lot in
an early episode and manaus in
brazilian amazon yeah so in short
we blew it by not taking the virus
seriously
by politicizing it we have made it
impossible
that we could deploy a rational policy
because half the population will suspect
it's a trick no matter
what um and the other half the
population has decided that if you
question
anything about the policy at all you're
a nazi or something right you're right
you're an anti-vaxxer you're at this
year or that yeah like
yeah and and that largely from the
people who claim to be all pro science
right so in effect because we blew all
of the other opportunities we had to
control this
we're now in a situation where well
these vaccines damn well better work
because we have
you know we've blown every opportunity
to limit this in some other way
yeah where but i mean i have i i hope i
have hope for ivor macden or evermechten
whoever it's pronounced
um just with that one important caveat
that it can't it's not
a one-for-one replacement for a vaccine
you know vaccines
and treatments um are different
approaches to diseases
and um you know i've we we've been you
know hoping for
we've been actively hoping for for
instance malaria vaccine since we
began travel since that moment when um i
ended up on
the run in guatemala not really but um
you know that very first trip that we
took through
um through latin america where we got
all of the necessary
vaccinations for tropical diseases that
you don't end up with if you're just
living in the u.s but also had to take
malaria prophylaxis with us and there's
not a good malaria prophylaxis out there
it all has
weird side effects and then the
treatment is different and
you know a vaccine would simply be
preferable right simply be preferable
sometimes they're possible and sometimes
they're not and you know
and for malaria it seems highly elusive
right so
uh i mean the lesson here and actually i
think it was jeffrey miller who
um he had a tweet poll that he put out
asking people if they thought
that our experience with covid would
make us better next time
worse next time or oh that's interesting
and my feeling is actually it's going to
make us worse um
i think that didn't win in his poll but
uh but anyway um the lesson for next
time were we inclined to
learn lessons anymore um would be
you take every opportunity to limit
these things
right and you use them for their value
to the extent that you can make some
people
less sick with some sort of with a drug
for example
even if they are sick and still transmit
it right
less sec is less sick to the extent you
know
the lockdown thing it's just so clear to
me
it would have been very it would have
been harder to sell people on
a lockdown that really kept you away
from other people
early on because it's more extreme but
at the very least now
that we've had endless lockdown and
everybody has grown so fatigued
of it we ought to understand you know
the wisdom
ought to be wow i would prefer if you
could teleport me back to the beginning
of this
i'll take the six weeks i really will
i'll take the six weeks gladly
yeah in order not to be here and six
six weeks of um isolation
and loss of economic activity seemed
impossible back in march
and now we're looking at nine months and
more and more and more and more yep
and you know some places have gone well
out of lockdown here in portland
and we've we've been in some sort of
soft either hard or a soft lockdown the
entire time yeah nothing
you know things have never gone back to
normal since mid-march
oh absolutely yeah
all right um let me get through
two more here and then actually three
more here because one of them is just a
comment
uh and then we'll move to next hours
uk minister liz trust gave a speech at
the center for policy studio
studies wow that's not studies that's
not a word studies
no i'll try again uk minister liz trust
gave a speech at the center for policy
studies
that equality should be based on facts
not fashion she even talked about
foucault
again the uk kemi badnak
i don't know is openly critical on crt
there is hope
thanks that's just a comment but uh
always good to hear and it does
boy it does feel like in some regards
you know especially
i just want the the part that i'm most
highly attuned to
is the sex-based differences and the
inroads that trans rights activists are
making to
sex-based differences in the law
that the uk is well ahead of the u.s and
canada on this
and i'm not sure exactly why that is um
but you know whatever whatever you guys
are doing over there please
please export it please bring it over
here
um okay what's the evolutionary
advantage of the humans female menstrual
cycle being so similar on average the
lunar cycle
i postulate the hunter-gatherers hunted
when the moon is full but spent the
darkest nights making babies
um i'm
[Music]
not sure what we should do with this
um there is i believe
a very compelling
hypothesis is this the place for it
um sorry i gave you nothing yeah
let's just say i believe maybe maybe not
well i will i will say that i don't
think
um that hunting when the moon is full
and spending the darkest nights making
babies
is going to be the answer because we are
precisely not
um typically linked up like that um that
even within populations and there have
been
you know for a long time it was thought
oh you know women you know in in all
in like in all female dorms and such you
know end up having menses together and
it turns out that's much less true than
um than early evidence suggested so um
specifically one of the reasons that we
are
as little sexually demorific as we are
and that we are as much tendon to
monogamy as we are
as humans as compared to say chimps or
bonobos our closest extent relatives
um it's precisely because we don't have
uh a monopolizable timing on
reproduction
um that you know all women are not
actually making you know
getting pregnant at the same moment um
in like a lunar cycle
so i think that the second part of that
is not going to be right right so here's
what i will say i will give you a teaser
and
you know i i understand that there's a
debt involved in this that i
i owe you the explanations that we have
held back here but what i will say
is that i believe this has everything to
do
with the moon that it is the moon
it is not the moon's gravity affecting
women as it does tides or any of the
other foolishness that's been
suggested on this front um but that this
is not an accident and there is
something
very special about uh the moon and that
it shows up in all kinds of places
that you don't expect not all of them
having to do uh with reproduction so
anyway yes think about the moon and
uh and it's phased timing
and things like that and uh we will
revisit this sooner rather than later
awesome um just a book recommendation
for game theory
prisoner's dilemma by william poundstone
part von neumann biography part game
theory overview part cold war history
so that sounds like potentially exactly
the kind of thing we've been
looking for thank you for that
recommendation again it's called
prisoner's dilemma
by william poundstone um and i'm gonna
switch
that yeah i just did um i'm gonna switch
now but there's a question here
um from someone who says um i'm a
lesbian who's never conformed to sex
stereotypes and i'm curious what makes
real trans i promise we'll return to
that one
um in episode 60. uh now i need to
find this hour's questions
did you draw a line here zach there it
is
all right um
wokism is so infectious because it fills
the religion-shaped hole in people's
lives
true what i like the i like that way of
putting it actually
so so the question can i just read the
rest of the question first
what if the best way to prevail over it
is to come up with a new religion-shaped
thing
can you think of some tenets to base it
on
um so again i think you've nailed the
the phenomenon exactly right it's the
religion-shaped
whole and the problem is people who
notice that there is a religion shaped
hole
in general in people when they lack a
religion
often come up with the idea that we need
to create one
which we don't but the idea that one has
to come up with
something that conforms to those uh
constraints
is probably right well i like the
framing too in the second part of the
question
a religion-shaped thing right that's
what i'm saying exactly
it's exactly the right idea right so in
some sense and we advocate for something
like this in our book not with respect
to
religion but the idea that there are
certain human needs
that exist as a you know that they are
wired into us in a way that we cannot
just simply wish them away even if we
wanted to
right you know jealousy is actually good
good example of this right
jealousy is deeply built in and the um
you know the wisest people in the
polyamorous community recognize that
working around
that thing is a huge struggle and we can
debate whether or not it's worth it but
the point is you can't wish away the
jealousy just because
it doesn't make any sense in 2020 um
or because you find it unfair right it's
there
so the question is how can you work
around the constraint and
there are lots of places where this is
what we have to do we have to recognize
what kind of animal we are we may be
living in novel circumstances where
that thing that we once were is a bad
match
but you have to you know uh jim rutt
is fond of um saying uh
that no system predicated on
a new man is viable right
yeah that there are lots of people who
want to rebuild
humans so that they can live in some
better way and the point is now any any
time you do that you've just told us you
don't know how to
build the system so no and that's i mean
that's
the other place where that shows up in a
more common form for
probably everyone has heard like when
you're getting when you're getting into
a relationship with someone if
you imagine you know if you really like
them except they really need to change
in order to conform to anything you're
going to be
able to live with like no it's not that
people can't change but
um if if if having
if having functionality requires that
change will happen
in some way that you have in your head
it's you can't expect that it will be
functional yeah
and so just to say you know jim rutt who
many viewers
in this case just viewers will be
familiar with um but he along with
jordan hall who we earlier had a
question that included
and you uh were sort of a substantial
part of the game b
group that was talking about things like
jubilee as possible responses
right so we were talking about how to
build a system that would replace this
one would
preserve its values and not suffer its
uh
its harms and unintended consequences
and so we spent a lot of time
and basically the ability to say look
anything that depends on us being
different than we are
is not worth talking about right right
we are what we are and then you have to
build a system that works for that so
yes
yeah the religion shaped hole is the
point so
well done yeah
uh ba humbug the next one says yeah
uh this one brett should i read it
sure okay sam harris recently said he
was no longer in the idw
could it be because of your remarks
about his trump derangement syndrome
seems very childish either way what's
going on with sam
is it time for a brett sam conversation
uh let's be careful here i do think he
was responding
to our comments and
um i also
think that i owe him an apology i think
he probably thinks i owe him an apology
i don't think it's for the i don't think
i owe him the apology for the thing he
thinks it's for but anyway i would be
very interested in having that
conversation with him
and frankly i think there's a very good
reason
um to do it which is that to the extent
that we find ourselves
on two different sides of something
you know how to understand uh trump and
the trump era
it's a pretty good mirror for
a civilization-wide
wound you know a tear in the
fabric of our collective sense of
ourselves and so
uh basically i think um
i think i screwed up but i also think
that
um i don't think i screwed up
understandably and the ability to figure
out what one does
having been in that situation uh is i
think a model for lots of people who are
going to find themselves
confronted with people in their lives
that they no longer know how to interact
with on the basis of
stuff that went down during 2020 as we
tried to figure out what to think of the
election and
trump and all that so anyway sam if
you're out there i would certainly
welcome it and i think it could be
useful
for more than just us
hey what are the skulls and moth behind
you guys
there's a muscle yeah well this is a
lepidopteran let's put it
put it at that um yeah the
skulls we have a
bear and a another bear
this one being also a seal and uh the
moth
is a sculpture from uh
artist on salt spring island yeah which
is the um
well here in the us we refer to them as
the canadian san juans
uh in canada they actually call them the
gulf islands islands
off the coast of uh british columbia in
the strait of san juan de fuca ish
between
vancouver island and vancouver between
vancouver island and the mainland
between vancouver and vancouver right
right exactly
um anyway uh very gifted interesting
artist who works in metal and glass and
uh
anyway if you're up on salt spring
island yeah we have a few of these can't
be too hard to find
yeah um but yeah two bears um one of
which is a seal
yep two bears one of which is a seal
that doesn't sound like english to many
people i'm sure but it is
owen gilbert's natural reward drives the
advancement of life
is that similar to explorer mode and
there's a link
natural reward drives the advancement of
life
well that sounds more like selection to
me explorer modes
is to to give you a short version
explorer modes is the idea
that if finding adaptations is good
which it clearly is in evolutionary
terms
then one of the adaptations that is
surely likely to be discovered
is a way of accelerating the process of
adaptation
and therefore exploring space in a
deliberate
when i say space i mean design space
exploring design space in a deliberate
way rather than a haphazard random
way um anyway it's another one of those
concepts that i really want to spell out
in
rigorous detail because i think it is
worthy of scrutiny and challenge
and i think it will triumph if
properly viewed but we haven't gotten
there yet so far what we've gotten is an
informal
description which has um uh
caused a number of people to get their
knickers in a twist
how should someone who has recovered
from covid handle the calculation
between the uncertainty of lasting
natural immunity
versus the risks of a vaccine wait this
was about someone who has recovered from
yeah
if it were me um i would not try to be
first second or third in line for the
vaccine
um i mean it depends on how
forward-facing your work is
um yeah i gotta say i don't understand
why we haven't had this conversation
should people who have had covet be
getting this at all well that's
so presumably
and i actually don't remember what's in
that new england journal
medicine paper with the 40 plus thousand
volunteers
none of them i
i think that they made sure that they
were looking at naive participants
who had not been exposed who had not
tested positive for covid
so i think the answer to this is at
least so far as i know we have
no idea what the vaccine might do
if you've if you've already had it is it
you know
exactly as safe which is to say
hopefully very safe and maybe not
but much less effective because it's
only building on natural immunity you
already have
is it really hardly effective at all
because you've already got all the
efficacy that your immune system is
going to have because you've already
been exposed both of those are
possibilities well
let's put it this way what we do think
we know
is that at least on this time scale very
few people get covered twice
yeah so if that's the case yeah and the
dangers here
exist by virtue of the fact that we
don't know what happens never mind
whether it has a different i mean
not never mind but you know it's a
secondary layer of consideration
whether there's some effect that comes
to people who've had covid because their
immune systems aren't and i even
look at the virus and look at the
vaccine differently that's a likely
thing
yeah but before you ever get there
the good of giving people who've already
had covid this vaccine
is pretty small as long as their
immunity from covid
lasts and so we shouldn't be
experimenting on anybody
when a there's not enough vaccine to go
around and b
we don't have any idea what the hazards
are you know at the very least we've got
a large number of people who've had
covid
and they shouldn't need this so and then
you know this gets right to the question
which is
there is going to be some kind of
draconian
you're not allowed to do these things
travel air travel
or go to a concert or whatever unless
you can establish that you've had this
vaccine
and is that the reason that we're going
to expose people
who have had covid to a vaccine that as
far as we know they don't need and might
never need
to come out of lockdown in order to make
sure that everybody has some card that
says they've been
vaccinated this is insane um so we
should absolutely and you know if we had
been
slower on the testing front we would
have tested against different
groups there were a lot of people who
were excluded apparently
from this study it wasn't that big a
study and
in order to be able to see the effects
this was very limited who it was who it
was given to and so
there's a lot we don't know about how
this will interact with other other
parameters and there's really no excuse
for us
seeking to vaccinate everybody
especially a category of people who have
effectively been vaccinated by
the virus itself yeah
what is what is the purpose of symptoms
like a runny nose when you're little
no when you're ill um is it mostly the
virus manipulating your body to conquer
territory inside and outside the body
to what proportion are symptoms useful
to us um
i.e for purging um so
dick alexander my phd advisor used to
talk about the moment when you stop
coughing
on behalf of your pathogen and start
coughing on your own behalf
the idea being that initially it's
triggering you to cough because it gets
spread
by your doing so and at some point uh
you are
coughing to get rid of you know mucus
that has to do with
dead cells and other particles it's so
brilliant and this i mean this is again
the problem with categories which we
need
but um in 2020 everyone is scared of the
person who's coughing
and some coughs there's no reason for
you to be scared
you don't want to be in their physical
space like you know wants to be coughed
on but but part of that is just
uh because it's hard to tell the
difference between an
infectious cough and a i'm trying to
clear myself of this thing but it's all
dead and i'm not infectious anymore
cough yep totally so your question is a
good one i think the runny nose
um has a lot to do with spreading stuff
because i mean
if you think about it also we have the
benefit in so many different ways
of you know running water and
soap that you know that happens to be
distributed around the landscape all
over the place
but imagine yourself sick with you know
whatever the flu a cold or whatever
and having no access to uh running water
or having it only in a river where you
have to be over there right you're
constantly like
you know you're dripping and you're snot
rocketing and it's all over you
right and at some point the um the
particles are
dead and they've been out in the world
long enough that they're not viable
anymore but the point is you're kind of
an
active spreader of this stuff until
you're not sick anymore
so yes anything that triggers a symptom
that causes spread
is obviously going to be favored and you
know we have extraordinary examples
of this in other realms like rabies
you know causes you to um froth at the
mouth
and uh be angry enough to bite just
about anyone
and uh you know it just so happens that
it's transmitted by a frothy mouth
bite um or uh cordyceps
fungus that causes yes that's where i
was gonna go insects to climb ablative
grass before
or a tree or canopy tree something i
think there's one that they
climb a blade of grass and they grip it
with their um
with their vehicles yeah what's the
other term for them
chalicery if they're spiders i can't
remember it but anyway they grip
before they die and sprout fruiting
bodies you know so
they're there when their sheep comes
along and uh
i'm i'm mixing two things i think you
are because i have found sheep to be
vanishingly rare in the rainforest where
cortisones tend to be that's true that's
true
um but anyway i think there are two
things going on there's one creature
with a
two-part life cycle that puts itself in
the path of a grazer
and then there's another one which is
cordyceps which just goes to a high
place and uh
at cordyceps that genus it's like
there's like hundreds and
many of them may maybe the vast majority
of the cordyceps fungi are
um like specialized for a particular
host so you got like cicada hosts and
grasshopper hosts and you know of course
cicada isn't one thing and grasshopper
isn't one thing so you know
highly specialized but they cause
behavior in the host
that enhances transmission of the
pathogen absolutely and this reminds me
last time you and i were in the amazon
which was this year
i can only say that for another two
weeks so i'm just going to keep saying
it
we encountered uh a very nice uh
corpse of a cordyceps infection
no it was a very nice corpse it was a
very nice corpse of any cordyceps
infected
insect and i don't remember how
successful i was at uh
photographing it i think i did all right
but anyway it reminds me
when we were there right oh you were
just gonna say yes
we should do an episode yes where we uh
look at the photographs that we have
brought back
and talk about what's out there and what
it's like to go looking for it and
yes all those things yes we should
definitely do it 100
good being so self-aware or are you
philosophical zombies
how do you two consistently stoke the
flames of romance
can relationships transcend their
evolutionary biological origins and
contain meaning
beyond being mere strategies of
darwinian evolution
also hashtag free little win totally
um interesting question uh you know i
mean
look i mean you are adaptively wired
to uh to want what is good for you
and the fact that nobody else could
tolerate me means that it makes
perfect sense for me to um find you
unendingly
wow that's a terrible thing to say
no you're taking it the wrong way i'm
just saying things are very clear from
my perspective i don't know
what keeps you going but um
am i making this worse yes very much so
thanks dude thanks for the question um
yeah
i don't know what to say there i i think
i do know it but you know
can relation go on it's
it's a never-ending adventure and it uh
yeah i will speak for myself though i
have a feeling uh i'm partially speaking
for you
here too which is that um having
been on an adventure since we were you
know
20 yeah not quite 20 yeah um
means that there's a whole huge history
and storehouse of stuff that we share
you know in some sense we partially grew
up together
and yeah yeah we've known each other
since we were 16.
yep and uh have been together since we
were very young and that means that
there's an awful lot of stuff um
there which i don't know like stuff
but you know if you believe if you
believe sitcoms if you you know if you
take the sitcom model of monogamy
um then that should just mean that we're
even more
tired of each other and and bored and uh
you know haven't
haven't had any fun since you know
1990 or something no that was the year
we got together-ish 89 something like
that anyway um
but that's not right and so yeah being
able to
actually adventure together uh be that
in you know geographic space
or uh psychonaut space or physical space
or you know any number of things
and and not being able to predict
with exact accuracy and precision
what the next day week a month year is
going to look like
is amazing and it is part of what makes
lockdown hard for everyone
yeah absolutely everyone is that things
have become
so predictable in so many ways that it's
harder to remember what is exciting and
serendipitous about life
yes in fact i was talking to a friend uh
quite recently about how
how terrible frankly lockdown is and on
so many different levels you know all of
the ways in which it's socially
corrosive of just all the most normal
stuff and i was
um you know i was reminded of a thought
that keeps occurring to me
which is how lucky we are
to be locked down in this way i mean
we're fortunate
we are yeah the four of us the eight of
us who live in this house together
including four humans and four
carnivorous yeah it totally sucks but
if you have to be locked down being you
know locked down with
uh people you like being with and who
challenge you all the time
and who know you well enough to say you
know
you need to go get on your bike i don't
care if it's midnight and raining
just do it anyway so anyway i do feel
uh super lucky and i also think um
yeah figure out what makes you feel
super lucky and then pursue that
no matter what yeah good
uh following right up on that one why do
the butts of bees and other insects
always shake
do they um i think
you know apis honeybees do a waggle
dance in which they intentionally shake
their butts
but it conveys meaning and you don't see
it because it's in the hive
yeah we don't see it well uh no there's
one um there's one part
so there's like three different
portraits yeah there's there's like
three different things that are being
conveyed i don't remember which is which
and
but yeah two of them happen in the hive
and then uh once the b gets the
attention of some of her hivemates she
comes out and does one last
thing so there's like direction distance
and what's the third i can't have
oh it's uh angle it's
angle oh so that's direction direction
so there's height oh is it height okay
so yeah it's like it's like
a 2d vector angle and distance yeah yeah
um so i think distance may be conveyed
outside i don't remember i don't know
but um yeah one of them is and we can we
could see them do that um
but i don't know do other insects
typically shake their butt i mean they
are some of them actually are
um releasing pheromones there's a
there's a butt releasing move
that involves pheromone release there's
butt releasing move
or wiggling move that does that there's
a there's a
heat releasing stuff there's fluttering
on the surface of the hive where there's
actually thermal regulation
of the hive but i think this person is
talking about the isolated bee that you
encounter out in the world
and um it's interesting there's there's
bound to be an explanation it may have
something to do
with um
i want to be very careful i don't make
an error but i'm wondering if it could
have a respiratory component
um boy it's possible so in general
they've got
breathing through sphericals that are
all over yeah yeah
yeah but i don't i don't know insect a
and p well enough
yeah to say all right maybe we'll look
into this one
but uh there's um
there are a number of possible answers
one is communication of something like
hey there's a b here don't
uh you know signal to grazers that you
don't want to eat this leaf because
you'll get stung
you know this is an animal that's
advertising its presence so that
could work it could be a respiratory
thing it could be
a um orientation thing you know the way
birds bob their heads that's effectively
holding something steady
as they move yeah um i don't think
that's likely to hear but
you know that kind of movement is there
anyway there are a number of
possibilities i wish i knew the answer
but sort of seem to do that sometimes uh
like they'll be totally still yeah
and then there's no i think they do that
yeah i think they do that you're right
and chameleons obviously not insects
quite true quite true i actually knew
that
i believe you did yes um
dna replication is costly so why do
differentiated somatic cells retain a
full genome why not only keep the genes
they need in ditch silence genes that's
a great question
that's a marvelous question oh i mean
you could also
i got a slam dunk i got little bits and
pieces but go for it what i would say
is the a
the genome is not filed in a way that
makes that
simple so you're talking about a huge
amount of editing
huge amount of editing and that editing
is liable to be error prone so you're
talking about potentially a huge in fact
oh
this is a good connection
so long ago as i was studying
telomeres and senescence um my co-author
and i were looking into the question of
hutchison guilford's progeria which is
this
phenomenon that makes little children
often boys uh very old
physiologically early in life and there
was a question back then in the 90s
about whether or not this was
a real old age where it just sort of
seemed like it turns out
it's real old age they have almost every
pathology
of old age with two interesting and
important exceptions one of them
being they don't get cancer yep
you want to show that so here's a a
young boy has the classic facial
features
actually can you show this one here
here are three sufferers um
so anyway the the two pathologies that
these kids don't get they don't live
very long
they don't get cancer and they don't
have mental decline
right they have the mind of a child and
they don't get dementia
and they don't get cancer and so those
two things are conspicuous and we can
talk about why that would be
another time it has to do with the fact
that the brain doesn't age the same way
as every other tissue that's one thing
and those of you who think that we're
going to defeat aging and
live forever even if you figured it out
for the body which you won't
you'd have to figure it out for the mind
too and you won't so
um there's that but uh
why was i on this topic oh yeah the
editing so here's the thing
so i predicted in that paper that um it
would turn out that people with
hutcheson guilford's progeria had short
telomeres which did not turn out to be
the case
the prediction was wrong but it was
wrong in an interesting way if
the answer turned out to be something i
didn't think to predict because i didn't
know about it
right um so in the same
just like the kala tricked with the the
twinning thing it was like this case
where
you know yeah i didn't predict the right
thing but um
it's definitely it's the exception that
proves the rule kind of thing
which was the cells of kids with
hutcheson guilford's progeria don't
stick and so i think they
don't stick they die they have to make
they have to make a number of copies of
a cell before they get one that lasts
so they basically going through a
lifetime's worth of
cellular reproduction very very quickly
persist and survive
yeah okay um and so their bodies go
through all of these pathologies because
this is of course what happens to all of
us over a very long period of time is
that you
run out of uh you know your cells age to
a point that they need to be replaced
and at some point your ability to
replace them
is expended because you have a limit
because you're avoiding cancer your
whole life
so anyway the point is were you to build
a system
where you had to edit out the part of
the genome that wasn't necessary and all
of those other cells
it would have to be really really good
at
getting exactly the right fraction of
the genome
and if it didn't then it would end up
screwing up a bunch of cells where
you've edited out something that they
need which would require you to have
more cellular turnover and so the point
is not
worth it now there are cells that we
remove genomes from entirely
red blood cells and mammals are
enucleated
the story is to make more room for
hemoglobin so that they're better at
transporting oxygen
i don't know if that story is right i
know that it's not true in birds and so
it's suspect because birds have even
greater requirements at least flying
birds
yeah it's interesting there's so many
converged
weird complex characters between mammals
and birds and that is not one of them
yeah it's interesting
um endothermy four-chambered heart
so like so many things that have to do
with running hot and fast but
not in nucleated red blood cells yep huh
i i'd actually never put that
together fast and put away wet some
birds get put away wet yes
yes but here's the thing all right love
your question
and here's what i'm going to argue that
you have cryptically
you have happened onto a case where the
answer is
phylogenetic constraint right there are
lots of things about the design of any
creature
that cannot be made better not because
the better design
isn't obvious and doesn't exist in some
other creature
but because getting there is impossibly
complex and difficult and or dangerous
right so for example uh the optic nerve
our optic nerve comes through the front
of our eye which causes a blind spot
cephalopods have it in the back of their
eye which solves the problem so the
design is
possible but you can't get there because
the
pathway to reverse the eye
goes through blindness presumably and so
we don't do it
but in this case i think the point would
be how much better off would you be
if your genome was organized in such a
way that all of the stuff
uh ups you know in some direction some
physical direction from
that point in development was no longer
necessary and could be edited
off right now
so you can't redesign the genome around
some dewey decimal system that would
make everything logically oriented
relative to each other you're stuck with
the genome
that you've inherited which is chaotic
in the way you've gotten it
that sort of thing and then the one last
thing i would say is
it is also the case that because genes
tend to have more than one
useful configuration arrived at by
editing
so a gene may have something like five
different versions
that get produced the point is a gene
that is no longer useful
in version a may be still useful for
using
version you know c and d i think this is
going to be a big part of the answer
that alternative splicing of genes into
totally different forms that that code
for very different outcomes
is one form of molecular epigenetics but
we would say epigenetics
sense restrict like the narrow sense of
epigenetics
which has come to become the dominant
way that people think of it when they
say it
which is say how is it that a genome
with only god what do we think at this
point like 80 100 000 genes
i think it's like 20 000 with five edits
even less yeah um can make something of
this much complexity
um it's going to be in things like
methylation of histone proteins and
alternative splicing and yeah that
sounds like a lot of gobbledygook but
it's basically different ways
of making the base stuff uh code for
for a lot of different things so um
you know this this mendelian
mendelian idea of you know you have
a gene for wrinkledness on peas and
color of peas and
all of this like he got he got really
lucky
with the particular plant he was looking
at and the particular characters that
showed up as very simple
would have become known as now as
mendelian traits
but almost certainly those same things
that he was
selecting for to get smooth versus
wrinkled peas etc
we're also changing other aspects of the
plant just like we see with like dog
breeds when you select for
something you end up with something else
that you weren't intending yeah
uh brett how what are we at zuck
okay let's go to the end of the page
here or my page
i think there's more beyond it but brett
i think you have circumcision wrong
and i'd recommend you listen to majid
nawaz on this he had done it to his
first summit is allowing his second son
to grow up and be free to decide for
himself
yeah you know i think if i'm recalling
correctly we we actually talked about
this with monty
when we saw him in london
we did years ago yeah no that was in uh
may of
2019 or june or may yeah when when i was
when
yes it was definitely in the past it was
yeah it was in may of 2019. yep so
um anyway look had a wonderful
wonderful dinner with him yes yeah
marvelous um
here's the problem
you got to take the the two parts of the
story that go together that tell you
just how complex this is likely to be
right the foreskin passes the test of
adaptation
it's clearly adaptive the process of
removing the foreskin
also passes the test for adaptation
right
what that tells us is that the foreskin
is serving a purpose and that its
removal is serving a purpose
and this is a chesterton's fence problem
right we don't know
what the purpose is exactly and there is
mixed evidence or worse about immunity
to pathogens it's quite
possible that in modern circumstances
the removal
is not necessary it is possible that it
is serving a purpose
that we would regard as immoral it's
possible that it is still serving a
purpose and we just don't know it
and so the point is i don't think it's a
question of wrong right
to the extent that your argument is
the foreskin is a natural part of the
body and therefore removing it is wrong
you have not understood
that its removal worked
we don't know what it worked to do right
and so
it's not there is no wrong here there is
a recognition of what we do not know
and to the extent that anyone says we
know enough to say
you know it is wrong to circumcise i
don't think they do know enough or maybe
i'm just not
up to date and they've discovered it in
the last year but
short of that um the point is
it's it's not clear this is this is an
open question and
i believe we should know more on the
other hand what i will say
is the belief
that this is a disaster for
civilization akin to fgm
no it's not a disaster right this is a
judgment call based on what we do not
know and based on some interaction
between
chesterton's fence and the precautionary
principle
um and in light of that
i just don't think i think the vitriol
around this
is completely wrong-headed
given your interest in philosophy of
science where do you come down on
scientific realism
anti-realism structural realism etc
i don't know exactly what those are
referring to
so there's just so much languaging
around the various
various ways of thinking about science
and i just don't i don't know exactly
what these are referring to yeah i don't
know i sort of have the sense that there
is reality
that we're a little bit hamstrung
figuring out how it works that science
is the best tool you've got
um that you've got to be very careful
about how you deploy
it because it's easy to do science wrong
and to look like you're
doing it right and which one of those is
that
right i retract my unity vote after
crenshaw did that skydiving vid
lol i don't know about this you do some
skydiving video
you know about this oh
uh we're talking about dan crenshaw
probably
um i don't know i i don't know that
there is a sky there must be
i guess i have to look it up um
here's the thing though the election is
over
thank god so i i don't know i don't know
that you need to retract any vote you
know we're just
it ends lol okay this uh
god that's a weird question to end on
maybe i'll find another one how do i
find myself a girlfriend or wife like
heather
serious question thank you i guess thank
you
yeah if i knew the answer to that
that's all you're going to say well i
don't know i i don't want to put it in
these terms but if i knew the answer to
that i'd be extremely
rich because i would or or something i
would have to
you know fear people hunting me down and
extract the answer but um fortunately
it's not that kind of question
i mean one one thing that we have said
in the past with regard to
um finding finding
your would-be soul mate whether or not
you like that languaging
is looking for someone and this just
just given
sex differences will be more difficult
to find in a woman than in a man
someone who engages in things that
provide them physical feedback
feedback from the physical universe and
one really good way to
find such a person is to go outside and
so you know be
be looking you know i either all bets
are off with covet and lockdowns and
such but
um you know go
join organizations that go on you know
group hikes or backpacks or
you know or biking or any sort of thing
like that
you know or um taking classes that
involve
again physical feedback in the universe
such that you know someone who lives an
entirely social life who can negotiate
what an outcome means and thus change
forever after the history that is
written about it
is going to be a much harder person to
deal with yeah
i agree but i also think in some sense
if i may now take a serious crack at the
question
in part i think we just have very wrong
expectations
about finding a mate and
the idea you know there's this thing
that one does playing video games
or i don't know what modern video games
are like but back when i used to play
video games
there was this temptation what it was i
didn't play pong but some that were more
sophisticated than that but
um but anyway there's a temptation uh
as you start a video game and something
gets by you
and your score drops reset to reset
right because what you know if you're
trying to get a high score it doesn't
make sense to invest in a game where
you're already starting out
uh behind right and so there's a sort of
sense that like
you know any even the mythology around
romance
is all about finding the one right
no it's not really about finding the one
it's about finding somebody
whose properties are such that they will
develop into what you're looking for and
you know i think in in our case there is
a i used to be
embarrassed about us having gotten
together so early because there's
this kind of implication that that's a
sad story
right that you know you didn't encounter
other people and
i i quite think the opposite now well we
both did
yeah we didn't we didn't get together in
high school
right right well it's true but we got
together early
and so the thing is if you're looking
late in life if you're
you know you're going to get through
your 30s and then you're going to find
somebody
right you're finding somebody who's
already you know
there are mostly what they're going to
be rather than developing together and
having influence on each other
which i think is has been very positive
so anyway i don't know
something opt out of whatever garbage is
going on out there with somebody
who has the you know the right
foundation
so one more just a comment this is a
holiday bonus for zach
i think i speak for many listeners when
i say we are so impressed and grateful
for your producer skills over 59
episodes
thank you to the whole family for
modeling a great family business
awesome yeah zack's zack's a rock star
he's doing fantastic work very much a
keeper yeah
yep all right um
i think we've we've done it i think
we've done it uh
so yeah all all the usual stuff that we
can say if i can find my notes
um yep you can go to as
zach's outro doesn't say anymore um
it's not working dub dub dub dot
store.darkhorsepodcast.com
use code christmas all caps to get 10
off to christmas
um join either of our patreons
right now the 48 hour period is open to
ask questions on mine
at the 11 and up level um for the
private q a that we have in the last
sunday of every month
brett's going to have a bonus uh
conversation for
people at his patreon at 100 a month and
up level next
saturday of the reasonable yep
yep and does every month usually the
first saturday and sunday for the other
group
of the month also at our patreons you
can
find the discord server go to the clips
channel all that
have a great christmas hope you had a
great hanukkah
lovely solstice pagan rituals for
everyone
try to stay stay whole and happy and get
outside
almost no matter how bad the weather is
and that'll help yeah and if you can do
something
watch the sunset on the solstice
something to uh
just mark that point it really is you
know
it's the point of hitting bottom and
heading back up yeah um
slowly at first but uh but anyway we're
headed in the right direction
and uh you know here's the thing today
we can say winter is coming next time
it will be spring that is coming
all right be well everyone
[Music]
you